whose Yoshi alright that's a dumb
question we all know that he's Mario's
magical dinosaur friend but defining
Yoshi's new island is a bit trickier yes
it's a sequel to the beloved Super
Nintendo original but what is it outside
of that relationship
honestly it's impossible to separate
those two games Yoshi's new game is so
similar to his old game that it splashes
around in those 20-year old memories
without forging an identity of its own
that's not to say it's not pleasant game
because it is a Yoshi's new island is
also quite forgettable Yoshi is a
slowest dinosaur around he can't even
run now we know why his kind went
extinct his lack of fast locomotion
dictates the pace of this platformer the
crazy dexterous challenges from its many
peers are nowhere to be found here
instead exploration is the key sure you
may be able to make it to the end of
each stage without any problems but can
you find every smiling flower the sense
of discovery is highlighted by branching
level design walls it appears solid
reveal their true nature when you come
close to them so be sure to poke your
nose in every corner much of the appeal
comes from exploring the twisty and
colorful levels the happy atmosphere is
so infectious you can't help but smile
Yoshi's new island is just a nice place
to spend some time
Yoshi isn't that mobile but he can't
hover and if I mentioned his tongue it's
kind of gross but very useful you can
gobble up just about any enemy if your
intestines are up to the task
poop out a proper a Yoshi is a fine egg
tosser stun enemies and reveal secrets
by throwing unhatched Yoshi's
willy-nilly and if you run out there are
usually more eggs nearby so you don't
have to aim that wall to progress and
there's really not much challenge
elsewhere either that's great for people
who would rather reach the end without
any real obstacles but it does make for
a ho-hum adventure sleepwalking to
victory just gets tiring after a while
even though you can replay levels to
find every hidden item there's not much
motivation to do so there's a little
variety that don't expect many thrills
from the detours either for instance
when you jump into psychedelic doors
Yoshi transforms into a sentient vehicle
tilt the 3ds to maneuver the jackhammer
or submarine through tight tunnels and
nab as many coins as you can these
sections provide a nice enough change of
pace but stiff controls eliminate any
potential join these mechanical
transformations sure Yoshi's new island
is easy but that's not why it's so bland
plenty of easy games have been great in
the past after all so why does this
suffer while Kirby's Epic Yarn excelled
it's all in the imagination more
specifically Yoshi's new island is
really unimaginable ooh the most engine
each level because there aren't any
interesting obstacles blocking your path
and the many collectables don't add much
either once you learned that those
floating age clouds hide an
out-of-the-way corners you're halfway to
completing the game so this is an easy
game with few surprises pretty ho-hum
experience the East seeps through the
health system as well and that's not a
good thing just like in the original
Yoshi's Island you carry Mario on your
back and he gets knocked off of an enemy
touches you you then have a few seconds
again and back but also you lose a life
it's a clever concept but one that
creates annoying encounters avoiding
enemies isn't a problem but if you do
get hit you have to suffer through
Mario's awful cries while dumbly chasing
after him the system doesn't make the
game any harder just interrupts the
already tedious piecing the health
system is at its worst during boss
battles here you need to put some
thought in how to hurt your mean
opponent once you figure out the trick
you don't need to do much to win
let the boss slam into you once you're
hit just scoop Mario back up and toss an
egg at the big baddie because of how a
health works the bosses pose little
threat there just another minor
roadblock on your way to the end credits
Yoshi's new island is certainly a
pleasant adventure it's colorful and
welcoming and even though its best
elements first surfaced more than 20
years ago it's still fun to explore the
branching worlds but the game lacks
a real identity and never presents
interesting challenges Yoshi's new
island works as an introductory
platformer but otherwise lacks the
excitement that would make for a
gripping adventure